hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday November 20th 2023 what's
going on how are you how's it going in
your world is it going good I hope
so I hope so I'm [__] burnt
out I'm wiped
out I am uh any other out that you want
to I am just my tour is
done I'm back from from Las
Vegas I think I've done all of my
business that I have to [__] do and I
think I'm off this week and I'm going to
try I'm going to try to do something
that I don't know how to do is basically
sit around and [__] do
nothing you know that's what the [__] I
want to do I got to get smart
again it's one of the dumbest things
I've ever said you know my problem is
I'm not I'm not SM I got to get smart
again no I kind of just uh was working
out I was was doing fine and then I got
a little
sick and
uh you know stop working out stop
stretching stop practicing my French got
[__] addicted to my phone
again I mean I think even when I have my
phone under control it's [__] insane
how much I'm looking at my phone just
looking at it constantly looking at it I
was on a plane today and I was like this
is it this is the last stupid game on
your phone that you're going to look at
and I just kept going I play this stupid
[__] you know word search
game and I'm like obsessed like I have
to do it every single day they have the
daily one you know to get you hooked on
it and I don't want to miss it because
if you miss one then you don't get the
bonus points for doing it 10 days in a
row and then 20 days in a row then the
home the whole [__] thing is
designed to [__] have you addicted to
it I was doing oh man a few months
ago you believe what I was doing I was
reading
books you know I was practicing
French I was [__] laying off
bread I was [__] killing it I don't
know what
happened [__] I don't know I just I
got I just I'm now like just like I'm
just another guy standing in line that
just put his name
in Sunday morning at Denny's hey you
want to go to Denny's like everybody
else is going to do after church and
just [__] stand
outside next to everybody else staring
at their [__] phones it's like what
am I doing I only have so much time on
this Earth I'm going to sit here and
play these stupid cell phone [__]
game I'm sorry guys I'm going to
[__] I'm in a a bizarre place right
now I'm also [__] upset because I I
[__] bet the Seattle Seahawks and
they had the goddamn game one I thought
and then they lost it and then they came
down they could have won it and they
missed the field goal
how [__] funny is that like you
know gambling on
Sports it's literally like my team isn't
even playing this week I should just
have the week off and just enjoy the
games but instead I get upset because
two NFC [__] West teams like I give a
[__] about that Division I don't give a
[__] about the NFC West until my team
goes to the Super Bowl and May and if
there's a [__] guy a team from that
we ever played anybody from the West oh
we played the Rams and we played the the
Seahawks beat them both yes we did in
happier
days
um anyways but that you know that's the
way the cookie crumbles you know I mean
that's how it works you know I do love
about sports gambling I love those guys
that those
professionals you know the these
professional guys and it's like you know
I'm I'm you know you [__] hire me and
I I'll give you
winners it's like well why don't you
give them to yourself
if you can pick winners what the [__]
are you doing wasting your time trying
to help me out for what are you Mother
Teresa degenerate
gamblers and you always look at them and
they they don't look like they got a lot
of money they look like they need
money gamblers always got that [__]
shiny bracelet or that watch or that
chain they got that one thing that they
they you know from that week that they
won and then other than that they
[__] look like they're hanging under
hanging out under the [__]
bleachers but anyways that's why I
gamble
responsibly I'll tell you if I was
[__] responsible I wouldn't even
watch the [__] with two kids at home I
literally dude I had to take a [__]
walk when that [__] I don't even
know his name missed that 55 yard field
goal and I'm calling him a [__]
cuz he missed a 55 yard field goal like
that's some sort of Chip
Shot I'm having a tough season I can't
remember the last time one of those [__]
a back door
cover a [__] drop pass a Miss field
goal any of that [__] has gone my way
it's unreal but it does make sense right
it does make sense I mean I'm going I'm
going up against [__] mathletes
computers and
[__] AI
scenarios whatever um having said that I
had a great [__] time in Las Vegas I
want to thank everybody that came out uh
played this beautiful theater out there
and um wrapped up the bill bur live
tour you know you know what's funny
every time you have a tour they want you
to come up with a new [__] name it's
just like dude there's just there's no
names
left like what am I supposed to call
it Bill Burr Serendipity the Serendipity
toour
serendipitous the uh gesticulation tour
like all all like it's like trying to
name a standup special like what there's
been so many of them what what is
left that's a good name what is left and
we'll take a picture of you and you're
shrugging your
shoulders that's going to be the name of
my next
special
right that's how I thought it was going
to work right I'll just be shrugging my
shoulders like what are you gonna
do the [__] are you gonna do I do want
to talk a little bit of [__] though
the um I went to that uh Formula 1 race
last night in Las Vegas it was [__]
amazing it was amazing and you know
there's a lot of F1 fans were going oh
my God what a boring track and all of
that so I was getting like all
self-conscious like ah you
know Americans what did we do wrong this
time what's the problem there is not not
enough turns not enough chicanes for you
for your purest heart well well you know
why that is Europe because we have land
over here all right your countries are
the size of States over here we actually
have [__] land we don't have to like
pave over some cow path all right that
Henry VII walked down when he was
telling everybody to go [__] themselves
CU he was eating all the turkey legs or
whatever the [__] those idiots
did yeah you could go from basically the
uh the
stratosphere all the way up to the MGM
going over [__] 200 mph I was sitting
on that straightaway and they were
passing each other they were making
moves down that [__] straightaway
over 200 miles an hour how many
overtakes were there I mean you really
going to sit there I get you don't like
America I get that you think we're
[__] stupid but you're going to sit
there and tell me that race wasn't
entertaining I [__] loved that race
and I loved how American it
was minimal amount of turns foot to the
fck [__]
floor bunch of passing it was over
fast [__] race was only like an hour
and 45 hour and 50 minutes and then in
the end there was a ridiculous display
of fireworks
like like that fireworks it could have
it could have ended a minute earlier and
it kept going just total
excess you know just all about the
highlights it was it was very American
so I I
felt that it was
authentic and I actually think that it
helps the sport because all of the
purists that love all those legendary
tracks around the world can now feel
more pure because they can compare it to
Vegas where we have like storm drains
popping up in [__] destroying
cars you
know I mean I think it all worked out
dude I had no idea Max for stappen who I
was calling Sebastian vettle that's how
[__] long it's been since I watched
Formula 1 I just got so [__] bored
with Lewis Hamilton winning every single
[__] week it was just it was
stupid um not stupid I mean I respect
the guy and all of that but it was just
like why am I why am I watching this and
it' be 72 laps 58 laps of Lewis Hamilton
in first place what's you know it would
get to the point sometimes he would have
such a lead they would they wouldn't
show him for like 20 minutes they'd be
showing the battle for second or third
place cuz that was the only place where
there was
action and now what is it [__] Max
forson has won 18 out of 20 races it's a
very dominant
time they got to bring back that [__]
kid in 2015 that was the best year
racing that I saw that was like Days of
Thunder meets [__] uh form Formula
One what the [__] was his
name I can't remember it was it was leis
Hamilton's teammate and they were
smashing into each
other it's a good time so anyway we went
there I want to thank everybody at at
Formula 1 we had such a great
time those cars were so goddamn fast and
we were so
close it was literally shaking the
stands that we were on the makeshift
stands and
um I don't know what all the [__]
complaining was about everybody was
[__] [__] moing and complaining was
like look it's the first year they're
going to make some
mistakes you know but I think overall
that was one of the most exciting races
I mean that's the third one I've been to
I've been to Austin Mont and
Montreal and that was Head and Shoulders
as far as excitement went Head and
Shoulders
above um the other two the other two
were fun but this one was just insane I
mean
like what was it Sergio
Perez um Max fappen and
um the [__] Ferrari driver what the
[__] his name L Clerk or whatever they
all were in first place at some point
during the race passing each other and
whatnot um it was amazing so love it or
hate
it that's what the track looks like I
mean come on you didn't think going by
the sphere was amazing you saw in the
end when the sphere turned into a soccer
ball little tip of the cap to the rest
of the [__]
world you know like there you
go there's the ball you all
love
um I did see yet another [__] video
on
um some English guy talking about
American
football I don't understand why they
have such a problem with it you know
what I
mean it's like you don't have to watch
[Laughter]
you don't have to watch the sport is
doing fine is it because they have those
stupid games over there I don't
understand when when is the NFL I think
they know it's not going to it's never
going to be that popular over in Europe
so
but it's a way for them to have four
games because doesn't the European game
come on like super early on the East
Coast I can't [__] remember I have no
idea all I do know is that my son likes
Cojack and I can watch that with them so
that's cool so
um anyway spent the time down at the we
stayed at the bagio man which I really
liked um felt like I was age appropriate
in that
casino I don't like being in those
casinos where I feel like it's a young
person
Casino you know CU then everything's
going to be super loud and it's going to
be nothing I can relate to and then
everybody's going to be looking at me
like is is that guy a
cop you know is he a chapon are you my
Uber driver you
know it's just like no no son I'm just
too old to be in this casino um oh
here's another thing I I want to I want
to like have this be a segment of signs
that capitalism is nearing the
end
um I don't know nearing the end towards
I don't know what going back to the
Industrial Revolution or a re ution by
Regular
People um which won't happen regular
people will never be able to get on the
same page as long as [__] ignorant
broke white people still feel like
they're more special than other races of
people you're not more special you're
the same let's all get on the same page
there's literally 350 sociopaths running
the deal there's way more of us than
there are of them and they keep us
pitted against each other all right I'm
preaching Unity here
people um my buddy you know I met some
of my my high school buddies were out
there in Vegas and uh one of them came
from I don't know what casino but he
goes I I just went to go play blackjack
or whatever casino and at that
casino if the dealer hit 22 it was a
push can you [__] believe
that like they're applying the [__] that
they've always applied every quarter we
have to make more money they've already
exhausted exhausted like how much they
can [__]
you with bottled water and all of that
like back in the day when the mob ran
it you know all they took was the
gambling they gave away everything else
everything else was
cheap the I'm telling you the end of
these [__]
corporations I got want maybe not I
guess you know what the the really
what's smart about corporations is you
don't know anybody's [__]
names and uh the smart Mobsters were
like that like you never knew their
names their whole life and they died of
old age and they kept their money they
went legit all of that [__] it was the
Dum Dums that were in the news wearing
the flashy
suits and uh doing all of that
[__] so I don't know anyway they just
apply this it's just like aren't you
making enough money off of people
playing
Blackjack that you have to add that
extra thing and this is another thing
too about gamblers like you should just
like collectively be like we're not
playing Blackjack if 22 is a
push you hit 22 you [__]
lose I God I wish I was good at math
does anybody out there know the
algorithm or whatever the [__] it is the
theorem to figure out how much money
that's GNA save them
or how much more that that [__] you as
the person
playing you know I mean think about that
just that one number it doesn't seem
like a big deal you know what pisses me
off is it's such a blatant [__] over and
such a greedy [__] move by the
casino but after a while you know people
my age whatever going to get old and die
and then like all all those other
younger generation is just going to grow
up where 22 is a
push it's like no dude you just [__]
lost you went
over and it only works for the dealer if
I hit 22 I [__] lose so you just
bought yourself another [__]
number oh people you know you want to
upgrade to
fries if the dealer hits 22 it's a push
what was the other one I had I'm making
the list here these little [__]
overs so they can try to carve out
another [__] five bucks off of
everybody oh that [__] with a
tipping is
included the Tipping the tips included
the tips included no no I'm going to tip
in cash I'm tipping in cash and I'm
giving it to the [__]
waiter I asked this waitress there I go
you know when they they say the tips
there do you get it well we get some of
it I go where does the rest of it go
they go I have to pay the front desk
person the [__] out of
here pay the front desk person and to
pay the guy that owns this [__]
business oh oh Billy's in a mood Billy
he's in a mood I did have a good time
though when I was out there in Vegas you
know there was a couple of ice cream
stores you know one of my favorite
things ever is to see a grown man eating
a [__] ice cream it's one of the
funniest things ever I don't know why
it's so goddamn funny to me cuz it's
just to me like getting in I if it's in
a dish it's not as bad but when it's in
a cone I just look at the person like
why didn't they just tie a balloon to
your
wrist you know and plus I feel like ice
cream is like that's like a very
effeminate thing to do that's like a
chick thing like who goes out and gets
ice cream as a [__] man you know and
by the way I love ice cream okay so I'm
not not saying that I'm a man
here that's what you know what it is I
am I'm I have
shame if I ate ice cream in public in a
cone I would have
shame cuz it's just one of those things
you know this those [__] you know
just standing on a street corner like a
red light like eating a
dut I you ever just see people just
doing it are like I love like you know
the coffee house
fatties those people that come out with
their [__] Frappuccino and like a
muffin or a bagel
and you look at them they just they're
ballooning up and you just like you know
I got to get it to start my day it's
like you're going to go with caffeine
sugar and all of those [__] carbs
it's like you're going to be you're
going to [__] face plant by 10:30 it
work this is coming from someone who
doesn't know how to [__]
eat
um I mean I guess I kind of know how to
eat but like these these [__]
[__] that learn how to eat this is
my question for you how do you learn how
to eat where is the right information
the food Lobby is so strong and they
have so much [__] misinformation out
there and everybody's [__] like
fighting for whatever crop it is that
they're selling as the latest thing
that's going to help you [__] lose
weight
um I don't
know yeah the ice cream the donut
gummies gummy bears
I don't know I gotta lay off cigars if
Snoop Dogg can [__] lay off weed
Jesus Christ think I can do that can
I just once can you go to bed without
smoking a [__]
cigar thinking about that field goal
kicker oh why they went into the prevent
defense is that ever going to work out
for me can someone just drop a pass that
makes me then cover
can I can I win a backd door cover can
somebody miss a field goal and then I
win the bet can that [__] happen this
year all right well I have nothing to do
now I'm done old dads came out it's on
Netflix it's done great I went oh I
didn't tell you I tell you went to the
premiere of I came back uh landed took
an early flight out
there's a new show uh new movie on
Netflix new Adam Sandler movie on
Netflix called
Leo and uh Stars Adam Sandler and a
bunch of super talented people I have a
small role in it and um I went to the
premiere and uh stuck around and watched
the movie and it's [__]
fantastic it's one of my favorite things
Adam has done it's going to be a great
movie to watch with you you know your
whole family kids and all of that but
there's a lot of jokes in there for
adults too so um and I got to do a voice
in it I got to be in the booth a couple
times with Adam and you know he lived up
to all of the hype he really is the
greatest [__] guy you'd ever want to
meet so check that out if you get a
chance
um so what am I going to do does anybody
have does somebody have the book
man on
[__] how to eat
right I've had to do this podcast like
15 times cuz I was so [__] mad about
that Seattle game that I can't even
remember if I talked about those [__]
guys who after they've lost enough times
gambling they then [__] start telling
you that they're going to pick you
winners I probably already talked about
it I just can't get over the fact that
people go to people like that it's like
dude if you could pick winners you
wouldn't be talking to me I'm a [__]
loser right
like what are you doing here and why are
you still dressed like
that
um why are you going on all these
podcasts talking about science why
aren't you out
sciencing you know why are you on
TV [__] giving people [__] five
minutes of therapy before you go to a
commercial break I just don't understand
any of those [__] shows but also
while I sit there and I'm laugh at that
[__] I will sit there and stare at my
goddamn phone and play these stupid
games that I know are just tracking
information or doing some sort of facial
recognition of me
um
yeah I think what I'm really trying to
say in this 23 minutes is that I needed
three days of doing absolutely nothing
and I need to shut my [__] brain down
I need to get away from the
TV I need to stop stop watching sports I
got to let this cell phone game
go I got to let it go I mean I am on a
[__] streak with this thing I have
not missed a
day um I've done it a couple times
accidentally but you can make it up and
it cost you 25 points and then I
immediately have to do things in the
game to get the 25 points back and I've
earned over 22,000 [__] freebie
points um I played the game so much
sometimes the end of my fingers hurt
from the friction of me swiping it on on
the
screen um entire flights across the
country playing this stupid [__]
goddamn game right I need to stop doing
that I got to get back into meditating I
got to get back into my
French I gotta [__] chill out I got
to chill out so somebody was telling me
you know went to that UFC thing Dana
White looked like a [__] million
bucks I think he's I think he's a little
bit younger than me but we're almost the
same age right he looked [__]
great and someone was telling me he did
this fast right a [__] you
know I don't know what a 3day thing
there's no way in three days he looked
that [__] good I think it it it reset
him maybe I don't know what was like all
water this day bone broth the next two
days although that sounds like like
what's how what's her face
eats there's an actress that eats like
that and she doesn't look good
I don't
know who the [__]
knows anyway I'm just going to get
through the podcast here people this is
what I'm doing I'm doing this Sunday
night I'm getting through this [__]
thing so I can sit down and watch
[__] Cojack and fall
asleep that's what I want to do give my
voice a rest and uh I don't know what
else [__] get my [__] together um
anyways congratulations to Max for STS
for staing congratulations to uh
uh F1 and all of that [__] it was uh
what a it was [__] amazing event it
really was amazing you know what's cool
so I saw these two guys they both had
like a full head of white hair watching
the [__] race and I just was
convinced that they were Italian CU they
were rooting for the [__] Ferrari so
I asked him at the end of the race I
said hey where you guys from and one of
them said I'm from Thailand and the
other guy said he was from Australia and
I said did you enjoy the race and they
said yeah it was [__] amazing and I
said good cuz I was getting
self-conscious everyone around the world
said this track was boring or whatever I
thought it was pretty exciting they said
this is one of the best races of the
year so it made me feel good CU you know
they're always [__] on us over there
you know that old [__] on that [__]
car show he's always calling American
stupid and all that which is so [__]
funny to me like there's this deep
intellect in England like when I go over
there I'm like
wow God damn are these people smart I've
never thought
that um I never thought they were stupid
but I was just walking around I was like
they they you know they speaking English
it sounds different than our English but
other than that cuisine's a little
different by the way England what
exactly did you do with all of the
spices that you took from India you
certainly didn't put them in your food
did the royal family only get it um air
gun
everyone all right
Bill me thinks air rifle or pistol that
shoots plastic pellets is the same as
having a gun around the house
oh I think he said my wife thinks an air
rifle I don't know what an air rifle is
or a pistol that shoots plastic pellets
is the same as having a gun around the
house I asked her what the injury or
death stats were and she said she didn't
know I said until you show me something
I'm sticking to my plan I'd like to have
some type of deterrent since there are
break-ins happening all around my
neighbor hood while PE while people are
home
thoughts
uh 100% I think you're in the
right you know and I actually think it's
it's
like
irresponsible to you know with with how
much corporations are
taking versus what they're paying in
taxes which is what is [__] hilarious
about the super rich is they always try
try to get broke people you
know middle class people upset with poor
people like they're the reason the
they're the ones milking the system and
these guys are like [__] declaring
bankruptcy and not paying taxes and
moving their companies outside the
[__] country and all of that [__]
just totally working the
system
um you know causing people to have to be
desperate you know I mean look there's
some people that are just born and
they're just [__] pieces of [__] I'm
not saying that but there's a lot of
people like you know after a while you
got to do something right like all these
[__] people that have
jobs you know they look at people oh my
God this person's a piece of [__] cuz
they they stole from this person that
it's like you know you are three days
without food and water from eating your
neighbor don't ever forget that okay
it's very easy if you have a [__] job
and food in the fridge to not go around
sticking a gun in somebody's [__]
face
um anyways I think uh your wife needs
some
stats and I also think that
her her idea is going to
change when somebody comes through the
door she's going to be [__] happy
that you have something it's like people
that don't believe in
God or even have issues with them like
me you know when I feel like a plane's
going to crash I still say a prayer I
mean I don't think it
works I still do it I mean I don't know
if it's muscle memory but it's not cuz I
believe
it you know when I I see all these
horrible things I mean you're telling me
all of these people in the Gaza Strip on
both sides aren't saying prayers every
day and they still get killed or their
loved ones die I just don't see prayers
getting
answered um but you know when you know
you think you're going to die you're
desperate you know you call up the
[__] in Hae
Mary hey God you got one in you huh can
you [__] help me out here through if
you [__] give a [__] that's how I
pray um anyway uh no I think I
think that you should be able to defend
yourself as somebody comes through the
front door especially as the man in the
house I mean other than that what the
[__] are you doing I mean she can give
you a kid what are you going to do you
know what you're going to do you're
going to take out your air rifle and
your pet gun you know and maybe a
[__] Chinese star or a [__] some
nunchucks you got to do something you
can't just [__] sit
there handing over a lazy Susan right
all right restaurant
rip you know I just realized I went
right into the questions without even
reading any [__]
advertising the [__] am I doing
here is it because I put them in the
wrong order yeah I put them in the wrong
order all
right guys if you haven't figured out
yet I'm [__] fried I am fried um all
right policy genius you know the
holidays not only allow us to spend time
with family but are a reminder of how
important our responsibility is to
protect
them I spaced halfway through that
sentence uh that includes planning to
secure their future life insurance is an
easy way to give your family peace of
mind
um it provides a safety net so if
something were to happen to you your
family can cover expenses while getting
back on their
feet um optional expenses to mention
mortgage payments or college costs yeah
you don't want your kid all of a sudden
to not be able to go to college if your
family po the house luckily policy
genius helps you compare your options
from the top companies and their team of
license EXP experts are on hand to help
talk you through
it even if you already have a life
insurance policy through work it may not
offer enough protection for your
family's needs and it may not follow you
if you leave your
job I love that [__] and then what do
what do they do with all of that money
that you paid into the policy the
corporate [__] they probably keep it
with policy genius you can't find life
insurance policies that's probably
another scam that they do we'll get them
to paying for life insurance we'll have
them pay into it for 20 years and then
we'll fire them and keep all the [__]
money um that we never put towards the
[__] policy to begin with because we
rolled the dice that he wasn't going to
die uh with policy genius you can find
life insurance policies that start at
just 292 bucks per year for $1 million
of coverage some options offer same da
of approval and avoid unnecessary
medical exams policy Geniuses for
parents caregivers givers or anyone else
who has people who depend on them they
simplify the process of getting life
insurance so you can protect the people
you love your family deserves peace of
mind a life insurance policy through
policy genius can give it to them head
to policygenius.com billur or click the
link in the description to get your free
life insurance quotes and see how much
you can save that's policygenius.com
Bill
Burr all right look who it is everybody
my voice is shot so I'm have to go easy
here it's all
zip
RR that's all I got uh did you know that
around 46 million turkeys are eaten on
Thanksgiving each year in the
US wait is this a pea ad or is this zi
recruiter think about all the people
involved in getting that there you go
let's make it about humans again think
about all the people involved in getting
that turkey from your farm to your table
the turkey farm laborers food safety
inspectors food production work
and more yeah all those turkeys that
need to die let's not leave them out of
it if they don't [__] die all those
people got nothing to do uh it's not
easy turkeys are calling zip recruiter
right now to find turkey farms that they
can commit Harry carry on it's not easy
to find people with the specific skills
required for these jobs but if you need
to hire for these jobs or any other jobs
there's only one place to go and that's
all
zip and right now you can try it for
free at ziprecruiter.com how does zip
help you find top talent for hard to
fill roles well they send it sends your
job to 100 plus job sites so you can
reach more of the right people zi
recruit is powerful technology does the
work for you it scans thousands of
resumés to find great matches for your
job zi recruiter lets you invite the
most qualified people to help apply to
your job to help you stand out amongst
the competition so if if you're hiring
discover what zip recruiter brings to
the table four to five employers who
post on
zip uh get a quality candidate within
the first day just go to this exclusive
web address right now to try zi
recruited for free ziprecruiter.com
again that's ziprecruiter.com bur
spellout bur B RR zip
recruiter the smartest way to
hire I mean I just
love love the love that I just love how
that that copies the smartest way to
hire you
know just wish you guys could see me I
always have my eyebrows up and I nod
when I read that line all right
restaurant
rip Bill what's the one restaurant that
no longer exists or doesn't exist in the
same way due to lack of quality or
change of menu that you wish you could
visit again I have to say old school
Pizza Hut where it felt like a classy
joint or Wendy's when it had this salad
in the taco bar I miss Wendy's when it
it the the the
tabletops were like old newspaper uh it
was it was still the same material like
for Mica but it was the the the surface
when you looked at it was these old
newspaper
um front pages from the past and they
were big enough where you could sort of
like read them they were like famous
ones and sort of random
things um
I liked old school Pizza Hut but I I
always hated those red bathroom glasses
that they put the soda
in
um all right if I could go
back yeah I must when McDonald's had the
blue
uniforms and Burger King had those
[__] crazy Brown orange and yellow
uniforms you know with the Rudy from Fat
Albert hat that went along with it
um and I always miss when McDonald's was
just trying to kill
you you know I like their menu better
like I haven't been there in years and
recently when I was out and
about my lovely wife had a craving for
it so I went through the drive-thru I
hadn't been there in forever and I
looked at the menu I didn't even
recognize it I mean it looks like real
Burgers now it's like this isn't what
you guys do
um no there was something else there was
you guys you got me on a spot here
because this is a great [__] question
and I'm just drawing a blank I know
there was
something oh I know what it is there was
these ice cream sandwiches that I was
eating during the pandemic and I put on
20 pounds like a [__] fat tited
[__]
um and somewhere during the pandemic all
of a sudden they just made him SL
slightly
smaller you know and I was looking at
Nia going like am I nuts these are a
little smaller she's like they are just
ever so slightly small another corporate
[__]
move what if we charged the same amount
of money or maybe raised the price
slightly and then made it slightly
smaller would they notice and if they do
notice just say that we were trying to
be
responsible you know because we're
worried about the Obesity
epidemic they would go like in that
direction
um what do I miss you know what I miss
friendlies friendlies used to have a
[__] cheeseburger that it wasn't on
like a bulky roll it was almost like a
melt and it was
uh yeah it was like their version of a
cheeseburger melt and I've never T and
I've ordered those other places they're
always too big and greasy and they make
me sick to my stomach or maybe I'm just
old now and I can't eat like that but
when I was a kid they had like those
[__] Aller french fries and they had
that patty melt oh my God it's [__]
delicious you know what else I miss
Bob's Big Boy when you'd go out to the
Midwest and they had those chocolate
malts those Burgers I missed that
place um I Miss Kentucky Fried Chicken
being Kentucky Fried Chicken instead of
being all ashamed of
themselves you know what I
mean you think with the
lgbqt you know all of those [__]
letters and everybody being like I'm not
going to be ashamed of who I am and
you're going to deal with me you think
that you know could be lgbtq KFC right
you think that KFC is like trying to be
like Progressive and it's like no you
need to go the other way you you should
not be an abbreviation you should be
Kentucky Fried Chicken you real I'm so
[__] burned out I thought that joke
was going to make sense but then I
realized KFC was them hiding not coming
out
um that'd be [__] hilarious if you
bought Kentucky Fried
Chicken you bought KFC and then you
[__] repurpose that song I'm coming
out and you and it was a big coming out
party that you were going to come back
and actually say Kentucky Fried Chicken
we're no longer
ashamed you know I look how they just
changed it to KFC but they're still
making fried chicken everybody knows
it's bad for you but it's [__]
delicious
right
um I think that's all I got off the top
of my
head oh I miss sun-kissed orange so soda
when it first came out when it was cane
sugar instead of that fake ass [__]
sugar that causes
cancer you know that's something I'm
waiting for a politician like that's a
great line for a
politician it's like you know this
country is messed up when the country of
Mexico makes better Coke than we
do cocacola that
is you
know like that's the big thing out here
I don't know if they have that back East
I've been out here for so long but
people like you know if they ask you
want to Coke dude they they got Mexican
Coke in there you're like oh my God they
got the good stuff and it basically
tasted the way it used to taste when I
was a [__] kid you know cuz that's my
thing it's like if you're going to kill
me and rot my insides can I at least get
real sugar is that asking too much like
how big does your [__] pool and Yacht
have to be all right I'm just a broken
record
here I'm just a man oh no what
happened what happened here is it still
recording do you believe in this part
podcast yes I do okay cool the old me
would have completely flipped out there
it's a posting a new beaten down me that
doesn't give a [__] all right restaurant
rip oh I already read that
castle sir Willam of Burr would you ever
live in a
castle no it just seems like it'd be
freezing cold you mean like a whole
[__] it's all made out of
stone I got those stupid throw rugs like
in the middle of a giant room
there's a couple of lonely chairs in the
corner I know you're probably too humble
to do something like
that this has nothing to do with being
humble it's just I I
just do they even have
Windows i g get that guy with the
[__] bow and arrows to protect
me
um now you're probably too humble to do
something like that but if you're going
to live in the middle of
nowhere wouldn't it be nice to have the
protection of some
walls Oh I thought you meant like an old
school oh you're talking about I mean
they used to build the wall
around their
Village isn't that [__]
nuts
like the the advancement in Weaponry now
is that we build walls that keep people
out of the country and back then it was
it was just like a
village and people would just come in
and they'd see you and their whole idea
was like let's go over there and just
rape and kill everybody there and take
all their
stuff I mean we really are [__]
animals I don't know maybe this
corporate [__] capitalism [__] is it
good I don't [__] know
um would it be nice to have the
protection some walls you know what
would be nice you know what would be
nice would be to have a god that makes
decent human
beings that sit down and talk out their
[__] problems instead of killing each
other wouldn't that be
nice I still don't understand how war is
legal you
know it's like follow these Ten
Commandments in your everyday life and
then but when there's war we can throw
this all out the [__] window
why why cuz you want some natural
resources your greedy [__] um need some
advice hello L Billy bunson
burner um I think this is the last
question as you can tell from my brain
and my voice I'm going to have to go a
little short this week I apologize I'm a
little short this week that's what she
said come on people back me up I had a
question about starting to perform live
since I played the guitar oh that's
fantastic I've been playing for about 8
years now and have always wanted to play
on stage but always got too nervous to
say yes when the opportunity
came oh yeah and then you [__] hate
yourself afterward right I'm now 21 and
think if some if I started to play some
of the bars in my town my success in the
lady Department would only improve of
course it would but you're also like uh
you got to get over the stage fright
first
um just make just make a [__] New
Year's resolution in November
next time somebody ask me to go on stage
I'm saying yes and here's the thing dude
I don't give a [__] how it goes you're
going to feel way better about yourself
than if you say no again all right so do
that do that for
yourself um the person says I'm from the
NorthShore so the music scene is already
pretty good oh they got a good music
scene out there that's fantastic always
dreamed about doing a live show
especially watching Classics like the
Isle of right 19 1971 ACDC Paris 1979 oh
yeah that's a killer but I've never had
the nuts to do it well you're only
21 get up there and do it man be
fantastic anyway seeing that you have
tons of experience on stage do you have
any advice on getting over the nerves my
buddy who's a good [__] is already in a
band and has offered to play weekends
with his band which could be a blast oh
was already offered you um I have any
advice
yes I got a ton of advice on that um
call your buddy up and say you want to
play you know this weekend or next or
next weekend
right
whatever either this weekend or next
weekend don't make it any longer than
that because I don't know if you got
family [__] this weekend with
Thanksgiving go up there I mean it's
easy just he's you got to know what
songs that you're going to be jamming to
so just [__] get those songs down
go up and go do it um and here's the
thing don't beat yourself up about how
you play all it is is about having the
balls to go up there when the time comes
that's it and then everything else you
know everything else it's just like is
out the [__] window of course you
[__] things up it's the first time you
did it every single Guitar Hero drummer
comedian actor politician every single
one of them has made every single
mistake in the book a million [__]
times a million [__] times cuz that's
just how it is and then you know
what those mistakes you learn from them
and then you don't make them and then
something else happens and and all those
mistakes become as just stories that you
share with fellow
performers and just laugh about them you
know I've been in the middle of killing
and I accidentally unplugg the mic and
then can't figure out how to plug it in
then everybody's laughing at me then I
lose my composure and lost the crowd my
face turned red with embarrassment and
all of that [__] you
know I plugged it back finally somebody
had to come up on stage show me how to
plug it in or something I forget what it
was it was some weird thing
or wasn't just a simple plug it in I
think it just took me too long by the
time I plugged it back
in the crowd had sort of turned on me
like laughing at me or something like
that and it was just like and guess what
it wasn't fatal and it was
funny and I told it to other Comedians
and they laughed and it made me feel
like a
comedian that I had a story of going on
stage and you know getting humiliated
and and surviving it so
um all the rest of the times it it went
pretty good and then all of a sudden I
kind of started getting good at it and
then shows some of them would be great
or at least great for where I was at and
uh I've been doing it ever since but you
couldn't have been more afraid of going
up in front of people than I was and I
got over it so if I got over it you can
get over it and um you can even tell
your buddy I don't know how well you
know this guy in the band just say like
yeah I'm not g to lie to dude I'm
[__] nervous about this but it's
something I really want to do so I'm
telling you I'm coming down this weekend
or next weekend all right and just hold
me to it and um dude you can literally
go up and just play one [__] song uh
but I can tell you once you get up there
you're not going to want to get off so I
I would try to learn a couple two three
songs just go up there man and [__]
rock out
man
um yeah I would say uh I would say
that's the deal you know I went to the
Ferrari [__]
shop I don't know where the [__] I was
one of those casinos when I was in
Vegas and I was thinking thinking like
I'll get something for my uh my son I'll
get him a little one of the little
Ferrari cars I [__] walk in there I
go I go are these for sale I see these
little Ferrari cars in like these glass
cases the guy's like he goes yeah he
goes they're
$5 I'm like for the for the
car he goes
yeah with his straight
face it's like what is the [__] Mark
up on that
thing
500% there's no way it cost you more
than what does it cost you four bucks to
make that [__]
thing so [__] stupid so [__]
stupid you know I had an idea something
I wanted to buy my
wife and uh for Christmas I had it I was
like I'm going to get that and then I
just
[__] went out the [__] window I've
been with her forever I I I don't even
know what else to get her like what
the I've got your bracelet I got
necklace I bought you a ring I mean what
the what where I'm out of [__] things
to do what am I supposed to
do I going to buy you like that that
[__] earring to the
nose thing like that that pop star back
in the day I don't want to fall in love
um got to figure out something get
her um
I don't know her I always tell you know
what I always tell her she goes what do
you want for Christmas I always say
nothing and then she
goes come on I got to get you something
and I just say get me an
experience so I asked for a either a
barista class so I can finish off my
cappuccinos with a little
design right so I can get attention from
people like oh where did you learn how
to do that oh just you know just been
doing it yeah don't give anybody any
credit
you know just take all the credit for
myself
or I I you know I saw this racing video
with this guy was bringing the car
around the
turn you know using mainly the throttle
sort of turning the steering wheel and
just whipping the ass around I'm like
you know what that'd be cool to learn
how to do that I'm sure they have some
sort of dad dad wants to learn how to
drive the station wagon faster down the
[__] Street class how about something
like that you
know what I love about both of those
things is it doesn't involve me having
to find a place for some new
[__] you
know what do you want for what do you
want for Christmas can you take me to
the
movies you
know I want to see that new Wen Phoenix
where he plays Napoleon I love Walken
Phoenix it's so [__] great that
there's
[__] that level of actors out there
you know well you just know like not
only they killer actress but they always
pick like great projects like he's he's
one of those [__] guys it's just like
if you just say that guy's name it's
like all right I'm watching it I'm going
to watch that it's going to be worth it
um and I still haven't seen killers of
the flower Moon [__] ridiculous but
now I have time off I might do
that I might do that on
Wednesday I think I'll have time I'm
just literally talking to myself at this
point all right I'm over it
whatever if we missed the [__] field
goal I've talked myself down from the
ledge and uh I'm going to watch the late
game here all right that's it you guys
have a wonderful
Thanksgiving um I what am I thankful for
I'm thankful that you guys listen to
this podcast that you guys come out to
my
shows um that you laugh at my jokes it
makes me feel great when I hear you guys
laughing especially when I do a new joke
um
so uh thank you for another year of
showing up to my show so I could live my
dream all right and with that go [__]
yourselves have a great Thanksgiving and
I'll talk to you uh I'll talk to you on
Thursday all right